now I'm gonna read you some things from
Friedman who wrote the disappearance of
God he was trying to look at the
underlying structure of the stories now
you know Friedman noted that the books
in the Old Testament were written by a
lot of different people at very
different times and then they were
sequenced by other people for reasons
that we don't exactly understand but
there's still an underlying narrative
there's multiple underlying narrative
unities despite the fact of that rather
arbitrary sequencing and that's a
strange thing you know I guess you could
say if you had a collection of ancient
books and you were trying to put them
together you'd try to put them together
in some way that made sense right and it
wouldn't make sense unless you stumbled
across some kind of underlying narrative
that allowed you to order them and so
it's not entirely surprising that that
they're ordered in a manner that's
comprehensible but Friedman's comments
on the underlying narrative structure
part of it was well we'll go through
this the books of the Old Testament were
composed by a great many authors
according to both traditional religious
views in modern critical scholarship the
phenomenon of the diminishing apparent
presence of God across so many stories
through so many books by so many authors
spread over so many centuries is
consistent enough to be striking
impressive and ultimately mysterious but
the hiding of the divine face is only
half the story there's another
development also extending across the
course of the entire narrative of the
Hebrew Bible which we must see before we
can appreciate the full force of this
phenomena and before we can pose a
solution to the mystery of this of how
this happened gradually from Genesis to
Ezra and Esther there is a transition
from divine to human responsibility for
life on earth the story begins in
Genesis with God in complete control of
the creation but by the end humans have
arrived at a stage at which in all
apparent ways they have responsibility
for the fate of the world the first two
human beings Adam and Eve take little
responsibility themselves and they do
not design or build anything when
they're embarrassed over there nudity
they do not make clothes they cover
themselves with leaves it's God who
makes their first
clothing for them Noah by no means a
fully developed personality Noah is not
an everyman either
broadly speaking he reflects a step
beyond Adam and Eve and human character
and responsibility
Abraham beyond the counts of divine
commands that Abraham does carry out the
narrative also includes a variety of
stories in which Abraham acts on his own
initiative he divides land with his
nephew lot he battles Kings he takes
concubines he argues with his wife Sarah
on two occasions he tells Kings that
Sarah is his sister out of fear that
they will kill him to get his wife and
he arranges his sons marriage in the
place of the single story of Noah's
drunkenness there are in the case of
Abraham the stories of man's life the
Abraham section thus develops the
personality and character of a man of
man to a new degree in biblical
narrative while picturing in him a new
degree of responsibility it is not just
that Abraham is kind lured kinder
gentler more intrepid more ethical or a
better debater than his ancestor Noah
rather both the Noah and the Abraham
stories are pieces of a development of
an increasingly stronger stance of
humans relative to the deity before the
story is over humans will become a great
deal stronger and bolder than Abraham
I don't know what that means you know
see it isn't it is certainly the case
that the individual exists in the modern
world the differentiated self-aware self
conscious individual and it's certainly
the case that that wasn't the case at
some point in the past and so it's the
case that there's been a development I
don't know if you could call it a
progression but a development of the
autonomous individual over some span of
historical time now we don't know how
long that's been but my suspicions are
it hasn't been that long I mean I read
once about a Neolithic ceremony that
involved the particular placement of a
bear skull in a cave and then I read
that and they had found these placements
in caves that were at least 25,000 years
old and then I read that they found
caves in Japan among the a new who were
the indigenous inhabitants of Japanese
territory and rather archaic people who
had the same ceremony with the bear and
that put the skull in the same
orientation and place in caves and that
that tradition remained unbroken for
about 25,000 years and you think it well
is it possible for an oral or ritual
tradition to remain unbroken for spans
of tens of thousands of years and the
answer to that is not only is it
possible it's actually the norm because
like one chimpanzee is like the next
chimpanzee right in the in the
progression in the biological
progression if you took a chimpanzee
troop now and he went back 25,000 years
and you looked at a chimpanzee troop
it'd be the same thing there's no
historical progression that's how you
can tell the chimps really don't have
culture because if they could even at
Crete one one thousandth of a percent of
culture transmissible culture per
generation it wouldn't take more than
about a million years before they'd have
a whole civilization and they don't
they're the same as they were and so the
continuity the stability and unchanging
nature of a species essentially speaking
is the rule that the variant is us it's
like what the hell happened after the
last ice age fifteen thousand years ago
we went from tribal uniform stable to
whatever the hell we are now it's this
transition from generic to specific it's
something like that and I can't help but
think that that's reflected in this text
and it has something to do with this
transition of consciousness from from
what from possession by the generic
divine to dominance by the specific
individual it's something like that is
that a neurological transformation is
that what this is a record of I mean we
don't know one of the things young said
about God because Young's relationship
with God as an object of belief is very
complex he in his technical writing he
always talks about the image of God he
never talks about God he talks about the
image of God he said that the image of
God dwells within that's not the same
thing as God dwelling within right we
could mean all of these capacities that
we have for transcendent consciousness
could be a byproduct of biological
evolution they could have no reflection
they can have no relationship whatsoever
to an actual transcendent reality
there's no way of telling the
transcendent reality seems to manifest
itself as an element of experience but
that doesn't mean that it has a reality
outside of the subjective even if it's
even if it exists as it is it clearly
does but
Friedman suggests that what's happening
in the biblical narrative is the
sequential emergence of the individual
as a redemptive force and that the Old
Testament documents that implicitly
unconsciously as a consequence of
descriptive fantasy and that that's
what's going on in the book and that so
the cosmos is under the control of
generic daddy to begin with something
like that and then that control shifts
to localized identifiable increasingly
personal and detailed individuals and
you see that in Noah and then you see
the neighbor ham and then you see it in
Moses and and then there's this working
out of what it would mean to be a fully
developed individual and that's what
these stories they're there they're
there they're like prototypes their
attempts to to to bring about the proper
mode of being right and so Abraham is a
is a manifestation of that because he
enters into a covenant with God he's
selected by God or enters into a
partnership with God it's not exactly
obvious God provides him with forward
motion and intuition and leads him
towards a successful mode of being and
it's complex successful mode of being
cuz Abraham is a very complex life
there's plenty of ups and downs right
it's it's not unbroken purity of being
towards a divine and Abraham lies and
cheats and deceives and does all sorts
of things that that a real person would
do and and Moses for example kills
someone and so these people the biblical
people are very genuine individuals but
they're given with all their faults
right with all their sins with all their
deceit they're still put forth as
potential modes of proper models of
potential proper being in the world and
the entire corpus of the Bible seems to
be nothing but an attempt to keep
throwing up variants of the personality
trying to experiment to find out what
personality works in the world